got a cellphone
well that's enough to make you a target
of police surveillance in the US this
snooping is being done across the
country using a secretive device called
a stingray here's how it works your
phone has to connect to a cell tower in
order to send or receive phone calls
messages and data when the sting rays
turned on it simulates this tower and
forces your phone to register with it
stingray can then collect your phone
number location the list of phone calls
you've been making and all sorts of
other data it doesn't just gather
information from individual suspects but
anyone who happens to be in the area of
an investigation and all of this without
a search warrant
so remember even if you are just passing
by the police might be listening in
you